all right we was off camera you were
talking about uh i asked you about doing
joe rogan you said you were the one of
the first joe rogan interviews how many
times have you done the joe rogan show
twice
you see we're like number 80 or
something yeah something like that i was
writing that number it might have been a
a little earlier than that maybe even so
i go on joe rogan's show right and uh
i'm [ __ ] up at the time what i'm
saying that just took mom's house you
see my documentary when they put us out
on my opponent yeah yeah i i i seen it
they just put us out the house and um
i go do the joe rogan show but you know
i'm wearing it with you know like [ __ ]
it i i when i left prison
i was already like [ __ ] whatever i got
to do if i'm homeless even in the car i
don't care i'm a win you know like
i'm just a billionaire sleeping in the
car so when i go to joe rogan show i was
like man joe i'm [ __ ] up
and he was like
man you need a t-shirt
and i almost put my head on the table
like oh
a t-shirt man give me some money i need
a i need a i need a boost so
i need a show man i'm walking downtown
and uh
this young white kid come up to me and
he's like hey rick i heard you on the
joe rogan so he all geeking and [ __ ]
like that and i'm like oh man
he's like man i got an idea for a
t-shirt and i was like oh another one of
my [ __ ] right
and uh he said the real rick ross is not
a rapper
and i say to myself that's the corniest
[ __ ] in the world but i always one thing
i notice about me is i keep an open mind
you know even though i might feel like a
certain way i ain't gonna like just say
like my way is the only way so i said uh
all right let's do it the dude say i'll
print the t-shirt out design and
everything i don't know who this kid
either right
so he designed a t-shirt i come to a
shop we take some pictures with me
wearing his shirt and he give me a
hundred shirts i leave out and i sell
all those shirts that same day
wow
so at this time i got joe's direct
number i can call joe whenever i get
ready yeah so i called joe i was like
hey man you know you told me to do that
t-shirt well i did it i got a t-shirt he
was like all right
i'm gonna set you up to come back on the
show so the next week i go back on the
show and i take joe one of the t-shirts
uh
because i was doing them with really
nice material you know the new t-shirts
so i gave joe the shirt joe put the
shirt on on camera
and next week man my paypal hit like
eighteen thousand dollars like ping ping
ping that thing just kept going
we thought it was broke
[Laughter]
eighteen thousand dollars was in my
paypal man we went got this apartment
and i ain't looked back since so that
that moment kind of helped
at that time was was you needed that
money i mean oh no we was [ __ ] up man
i had two babies i had two brand new
babies
and my girl because i wanted to have a
son as soon as i got home because i knew
my time was running you know i'm an old
man now
right so as soon as you got home you got
to work well i i never i've never raised
a kid right
and i've always wanted to you know like
i mean you know you could say i raised
my younger brothers but i slipped on
them because i would let them
you know go and do their own thing but
with my babies they don't get to do
nothing it's like of course you know
straight so joe rogan wearing that
t-shirt kind of
oh my goodness
i can't even say how many shirts that
thing sold because i rescued me on my
ass
[Music]
it did so well that t-shirt did so well
that right now it's like
five or six websites just bootlegging
that t-shirt that's so crazy i feel like
i've seen it like at the swap meet for
sure
the real red cross is not a rapper yeah
you know i still wear it
oh it's there
there it is right there i still wear
that joint go to the website and buy one
right now
when you when you someone who's known
joe rogan as long as you have and you
see the controversy with uh you know
what's going on with him you know what
are your thoughts on that i don't think
joe's a racist
you know i mean a lot of people say it i
mean i used to use the n-word
i used to use the n-word
but you know it's okay but it's a little
different when you use it yeah
but but uh it's it's i don't know but i
don't i don't feel like joe rogan is
racist you know i think he's getting a
bad uh rap for for using the word and he
apologized and he's i don't believe
he'll ever use it again would you go
back on the show yeah i'll do joe
tomorrow i'll be i sell a million books
let's say you'll sell a lot more books a
lot more t-shirts now yeah if i go on
joe's show right now my book probably
wouldn't have been the best i mean my
book already you know i didn't really
need you i don't really need
nobody to do what i do for real uh my
book has done some numbers
you know just uh the way i sell it they
just don't uh calculate
of course how about so amazon let me say
that there and saying i'm going to let
amazon sell more of my books than i saw
i respect that